a massive and dangerous storm is bearing
down on the Gulf Coast millions of
Americans are at risk from drenching
rains and damaging winds
tropical storm Cindy is her named it's
the first major storm of the season to
take direct aim at the continental
United States the storm reaches the
storms reach rather stretches across a
500-mile area of the Gulf Coast from
Texas to Florida right now sustained
winds are up to 60 miles an hour
parts of Mississippi and Louisiana are
expecting up to a foot of rain
New Orleans could see six to ten inches
David beg no is on the edge of Lake
Pontchartrain in New Orleans David good
morning Jeff good morning this storm is
moving slowly and we're still about 24
hours away from landfall but already
we're seeing storm surge here in New
Orleans
like here along Lake Pontchartrain that
is causing flooding and it was predicted
this morning you're seeing high winds
probably 45 mile-per-hour gusts here in
New Orleans
but across the Gulf Coast you've got
rain bands that are already rotating all
the way from Southeast Texas to the
Florida Panhandle we're talking about
more than 500 miles this storm as its
predicted now expected to make landfall
somewhere near southeast Texas maybe
Southwest Louisiana the rain from
tropical storm Cindy is already making
an impact on the Gulf Coast bringing
whipping winds Whitecaps and storm surge
roads in several states are impassable
as far east as Gwinnett County Georgia
the effects from Cindy have caused flash
flooding first responders rescued almost
30 people trapped due to rising water we
all try to get in the cars and drive out
didn't happen
here in New Orleans preparations began
days before the storms arrival trucks
delivered hundreds of sandbags to
low-lying towns threatened by severe
flooding this is a major major rain
event Ken Graham is a meteorologist with
the National Weather Service he says it
is critical that people focus on areas
beyond the storms projected cone we as
Americans get so caught up in that cone
right when the National Weather Service
puts it out we say oh that's where it's
going and outside of that we must be
good we've talked to the public we tell
them be ready the impacts are well
outside that cone rain surge all the
different factors with a tropical system
could be well outside that cone Mitch
Landrieu is the New Orleans mayor listen
we've been through this many many times
before
I don't want anybody to panic there's no
reason to do that but this is going to
be a serious event a serious event for
at least the next 48 hours probably this
is not expected to become a hurricane
Charley but flash flood warnings could
pop up again from Southeast Texas all
the way to Apalachicola or Pensacola
Florida may be thanks